Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, we are looking at trauma stabilisation. What is it? Why does it matter?
这些原则都同样适用。你还有机会直接赢取丽莎提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。今天我们要探讨的是创伤稳定化。它是什么？为什么它很重要？
And what sort of results can it achieve for the clients who go through it? What sort of results can it achieve for the clinicians delivering it? We're looking at getting research published and making a difference at the right time for the client. I hope you find this so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I feel like there's not much of an intro to make for today's episode actually because I think we did a really wonderful job of handling it as kind of almost a standalone
它能为接受治疗的客户带来什么样的结果？它能为提供治疗的临床医生带来什么样的结果？我们将探讨如何发表研究成果，并在合适的时机为客户带来改变。希望你觉得这些内容很有用。欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。其实我觉得今天这期节目不需要太多介绍，因为我觉得我们处理得非常好，几乎可以作为一个独立的
episode. I'm chatting with Amy Shipp who is a qualified clinical associate psychologist and we're talking about group programs for stabilization and I just found it a really wonderful, wonderful episode to record and yeah, I hope you find it really useful. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this. Enjoy. I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Amy. Hi, Amy. Hiya. Thank you for joining us. We connected on LinkedIn, which is the start of many a podcast episode that I say, but I just, I really love the interesting things that are going on in the psychology world and it just sparks my interest for podcasts. So before we get thinking about what we're going to talk about
节目。我正在与艾米·希普（Amy Shipp）聊天，她是一位合格的临床心理学助理（CAP），我们讨论的是用于稳定化的团体项目。我觉得这是一期非常非常棒的录音，希望你觉得它很有用。我期待在节目结束后与你交流。享受吧。我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾艾米。你好，艾米。你好。谢谢你加入我们。我们在领英（LinkedIn）上建立了联系，这是我很多播客节目的开端，但我真的非常喜欢心理学界正在发生的有趣事情，这激发了我做播客的兴趣。所以在我们开始思考要谈论的话题之前，
today, could you tell us a little bit about yourself and your kind of psychology history so far? Of course. So I am a CAP, quite a new role. I think many people are learning a lot about it now. And I first started with psychology back in secondary school and just really took a shine to it. Just found it really interesting in terms of just learning about why people did things the way that they do and how everything that we experience impacts us. And took it further from there really studied psychology at a level study psychology for my undergrad and initially I had kind of different thoughts as to where I wanted to go within that route so I took a forensic psychology master's with the intention of going down the forensic route and had a bit of a change of heart following
你能先简单介绍一下你自己以及你目前的心理学背景吗？当然可以。我是一名临床心理学助理（CAP），这是一个相当新的角色。我想很多人现在对它了解很多了。我最早是在中学时期开始接触心理学的，当时就非常喜欢它。我发现学习人们为什么会那样做，以及我们所经历的一切如何影响我们，是非常有趣的。从那时起，我进一步深入学习，在 A-level 阶段学习了心理学，本科也学习了心理学。起初，我对在这个领域的发展方向有不同的想法，所以我攻读了法医心理学硕士学位，打算走法医路线，但后来改变了主意，
the clinical route and that led me to the clinical associate in psychology role and the training course which has been great. I see very nice thank you yeah forensics I all my assistant work was forensic stuff but I always knew I didn't want to be a forensic psychologist it's just that that was the experience that I'd managed to get but forensics is not for everybody you know um I wasn't really that keen to return to forensics after I qualified I felt like I'd kind of earned those stripes and was looking forward to kind of non-forensic work but um it is the real deal there's a lot to process isn't there in forensic settings yeah most definitely and I think for me it was something I realized um was an interest of mine but perhaps not where I wanted to work
转向了临床路线，这引导我进入了临床心理学助理的角色和培训课程，这非常棒。我明白，非常好，谢谢。是的，法医方面，我所有的助理工作都是法医相关的，但我一直知道我不想成为一名法医心理学家，那只是我设法获得的经验。但法医工作并不适合所有人，你知道的。嗯，我在获得资格后并不太想回到法医领域，我觉得我已经积累了足够的经验，期待从事非法医的工作。但是，这确实是真刀真枪的，在法医环境中有很多东西需要处理，不是吗？是的，绝对是。对我来说，我意识到这是我的兴趣所在，但也许不是我想工作的地方。
clinically okay so a good experience nonetheless yeah and that's actually a really nice way of looking at it you know you can take a look but you don't necessarily need to make that your career. And that reminds me of when I was training, doing my doctorate, that you kind of, that's what placements are for. We're taking a look. We're trying on some different shoes here. We don't necessarily need to keep them. We can move forward and decide what kind of psychologist I want to be. And that found you working as a clinical associate psychologist. If people are interested in knowing more about the role and the training of clinical associate psychologists, we've had a very recent episode with Dr. Dawn Reeves, who is working in Essex Partnership University Trust, looking at that
临床上，好吧，无论如何这都是一次很好的经历。是的，这确实是一个很好的看待方式。你可以去看看，但不一定非要把它作为你的职业。这让我想起我接受博士培训的时候，实习就是为了这个目的。我们去看看，去试穿不同的鞋子。我们不一定要一直穿着它们。我们可以继续前进，决定我想成为什么样的心理学家。这让你成为了临床心理学助理。如果人们有兴趣了解更多关于临床心理学助理的角色和培训，我们最近有一期节目邀请了在埃塞克斯伙伴关系大学信托基金（Essex Partnership University Trust）工作的道恩·里夫斯博士（Dr. Dawn Reeves），探讨了
role for adults. But we also had an episode a little bit earlier on with Elise Dyer looking at the training role for children and young people caps so if that's okay I mean we won't cover that too much because we've covered that a little bit already but I am really really interested to think about your work in adult mental health and to think about how that's landed you with a publication and how you're hopefully setting the world of trauma-informed care and service delivery alight do you want to pick up that that baton run with that for a bit yeah it's been um it's been really interesting. I worked as an assistant psychologist in my current service
针对成人的角色。但我们之前也有一期节目邀请了埃莉斯·戴尔（Elise Dyer），探讨了针对儿童和青少年的 CAP 培训角色。所以如果可以的话，我们就不多谈这个了，因为我们已经讨论过一些了。但我真的非常非常有兴趣了解你在成人心理健康方面的工作，以及它是如何让你获得发表成果的，以及你如何希望点亮创伤知情护理和服务交付的世界。你想接过这个接力棒继续说下去吗？是的，这非常有趣。我在目前的机构担任助理心理学家，
before doing the CAP training and the service itself kind of came to light in the midst of the first pandemic lockdown and we recognised, and this is probably something that a lot of people recognize across the country and not just in the area that I'm in um this real kind of gap between primary and secondary care with lots of um lots of people falling through that gap and not the kind of service remit existing that can provide the things that those people need. And oftentimes that tends to be for people who are experiencing the after effects of complex trauma. So we had a real task in setting up the service, which was designed to essentially fill that gap between primary and secondary care. It's kind of a transformational project that looked at reducing that siloed working that was existing between primary and secondary and also third sector organisations
在参加 CAP 培训之前，该机构本身是在第一次疫情封锁期间出现的。我们认识到——这可能是全国很多人，而不仅仅是我所在地区的人所认识到的——初级保健和二级保健之间存在真正的差距，很多人落入了那个缝隙中，而现有的服务范围无法提供这些人所需要的东西。通常，这往往是针对那些正在经历复杂创伤后遗症的人。所以我们有一个真正的任务，就是建立这个服务，旨在填补初级保健和二级保健之间的空白。这是一个转型项目，旨在减少初级保健、二级保健以及第三部门组织之间存在的孤岛式工作，
to help us work together more collaboratively. So we designed this service that now exists with the idea of capturing those people that fall in between. And we take a lot of learning from the neuro sequential model by Bruce Perry and the phased approach to trauma therapy that's kind of been advised by Herman. And it's, you know, in a lot of our guidelines that exist now for managing and treating complex PTSD. So we developed this service that's essentially got layers to the service and is very formulation driven very trauma informed and as part of that that kind of layered approach we focus on that from that neuro neuro sequential perspective so the kind of lower end levels of our interventions or our support focuses on that kind of bottom-up processing and as you move higher we start to to approach those top-down processing
帮助我们更协作地工作。所以我们设计了这个现在存在的服务，旨在捕捉那些落入缝隙的人。我们从布鲁斯·佩里（Bruce Perry）的神经序列模型和赫尔曼（Herman）建议的创伤治疗分阶段方法中汲取了很多经验。而且，你知道，在我们现在管理和治疗复杂 PTSD 的许多指南中都有体现。所以我们开发了这个服务，它本质上是有层次的，非常注重构思，非常注重创伤知情。作为这种分层方法的一部分，我们从神经序列的角度进行关注。因此，我们干预或支持的较低层级侧重于那种自下而上的处理，而当我们向上移动时，我们开始接近那些自上而下的处理
methods and sitting within that is an online complex trauma stabilization group that we developed which we've we've recently published some research about amazing it's so important and it's just trying to make sure that we are you know we're mopping up any gaps really and in case people are listening to this thinking hmm primary care secondary care don't quite know what that is so primary care is something like your gp that you can self-refer to there might be lower level interventions secondary care is something that you ordinarily would need a a referral to and you might get kind of higher level perhaps more intensive intervention is that
方法。其中包含了一个我们开发的在线复杂创伤稳定化小组，我们最近发表了一些关于它的研究。太棒了，这非常重要。这只是为了确保我们确实在填补任何空白。如果有人在听这个节目，心想“嗯，初级保健、二级保健，不太清楚那是什么”，那么初级保健就像是你的全科医生（GP），你可以自行转诊，可能会有较低级别的干预；二级保健是你通常需要转诊才能获得的，你可能会得到更高级别、也许更深入的干预。是
is that how you understand the the definition the separation between the two amy if i got that right yeah absolutely and i think with secondary care it tends to be um where that kind of longer term support is needed as well. Sometimes multiple professionals to be involved as well. Lovely, thank you Amy. So tell me about your research then. So for the past few years now we have been offering this complex trauma stabilization group that's run online currently. And the idea of it really is to kind of sit in that first phase of that approach to trauma therapy essentially mostly focusing on things like safety and stabilization in order to prepare people for moving forward in that pathway to potentially go on to reprocess traumatic experiences and it's something that didn't really exist in this area we have um support services available for kind of single incident ptsd um but what we noticed is there's a lot of people that were
这样理解两者的区别吗，艾米？如果我理解正确的话。是的，绝对是。我认为二级保健往往是需要那种长期支持的地方。有时也需要多位专业人员参与。太好了，谢谢艾米。那么跟我说说你的研究吧。在过去的几年里，我们一直提供这个目前在线运行的复杂创伤稳定化小组。它的初衷确实是处于创伤治疗方法的第一个阶段，本质上主要关注安全和稳定化等事情，以便为人们在通往潜在的重新处理创伤经历的道路上做好准备。这是该地区以前不存在的东西。我们有针对单一事件 PTSD 的支持服务，但我们注意到有很多人的需求
being missed because of experiences of complex trauma so those ongoing repeated experiences of trauma that often start in childhood and And, and whilst the impact of that is in some ways similar to, to a single incident PTSD, um, presentation. So, you know, your intrusive symptoms, um, there is kind of that additional, um, layer, I suppose, um, which we refer to as disturbances and self-organization. So, you know, those things that impact, like your ability to regulate your emotions, that kind of perception of yourself and your role, as some people kind of see that. And also just those difficulties in terms of interacting with others and those kind of see that and also just those difficulties in terms of interacting with others and those
被忽略了，因为他们有复杂创伤的经历，也就是那些通常始于童年的持续的、重复的创伤经历。虽然其影响在某些方面与单一事件 PTSD 的表现相似，比如侵入性症状，但确实存在一种额外的层面，我们称之为“自我组织障碍”。所以，那些影响你调节情绪能力的事情，你对自己和自己角色的看法，有些人是这样看的。还有在与他人互动方面的困难，以及那些人际关系方面的困难。所以很多人被忽略了。所以我们通过这个小组所做的，本质上是使这些人能够获得他们需要的支持，以便重新处理这些创伤，并能够过上更高质量的生活。从创伤小组开始，这是一个我们运行的为期 12 周的小组，
kind of interpersonal relationships so a lot of those people are being missed so what we're doing with this group is essentially enabling those people to be able to receive the support that they need in terms of reprocessing those traumas and being able to live a better quality of life starting off with the the trauma group um and it it's a it's a 12-week group that we run um in an online format two hours weekly that of course this break there's breaks in that as well um but we we essentially move through the group um to provide a better understanding of why people experience these particular difficulties following complex trauma and how that kind of fits in in terms of the way in which our brains work generally as human beings and how that's altered through the experience of trauma and then providing people with strategies to essentially
以在线形式进行，每周两小时。当然，中间也有休息时间。但我们本质上是通过小组来提供更好的理解，了解为什么人们在复杂创伤后会经历这些特定的困难，以及这如何符合我们人类大脑运作的方式，以及这种方式如何通过创伤经历而改变。然后为人们提供策略，本质上
almost stabilize symptoms so to better regulate emotions to develop more compassionate ways of relating to themselves and to the difficulties that they experience um and predominantly the the group itself is based on principles of cbt um but we also draw upon things like um dialectical behavior therapy so dbt compassion focused therapy um in order to provide that psychoeducation about trauma and those strategies. We've run many groups now. I think we're on about group number 21, which we first started this particular therapy group around three to four years ago now. And yeah, just being a pilot service, being a pilot group as well, it's really important to us to make sure it's doing what we want it to do and actually having a positive impact for people.
几乎是稳定症状，从而更好地调节情绪，发展出更具同情心的方式来对待自己和他们所经历的困难。该小组本身主要基于 CBT（认知行为疗法）的原则，但我们也借鉴了辩证行为疗法（DBT）、同情聚焦疗法（CFT）等，以便提供关于创伤的心理教育和那些策略。我们现在已经运行了许多小组。我想我们大约进行到第 21 个小组了，我们大约在三到四年前首次开始了这特定的治疗小组。是的，作为一个试点服务，作为一个试点小组，确保它能达到我们想要的效果，并确实对人们产生积极影响，这对我们来说非常重要。
But also exploring, you know, like the service user experience of that as well, because we have this knowledge and these ideas that we want to share with people to support them but obviously the experience of receiving that needs to be helpful and compassionate and containing as well so that's what we looked to do in this particular piece of research we we did a service evaluation of this particular group um to look at the the outcomes um any kind of clinical change um but also exploring people's experience of that group as well lovely so important to measure what we're doing isn't it and you know we're doing that by doing outcome measures at the start at the midpoint at the end point um some services are asking you to do after every session as well but some of them feel like overkill um i this really resonated with me because when i was working in the in the nhs i realized that i was for every new patient i was picking up
但也要探索服务使用者的体验，因为我们有这些知识和想法，我们想与人们分享以支持他们，但显然，接受这些知识的体验需要是有帮助的、富有同情心的和具有包容性的。所以这就是我们在这项特定研究中想要做的。我们对这个特定小组进行了服务评估，以查看结果、任何临床变化，同时也探索人们对该小组的体验。太好了，衡量我们所做的事情非常重要，不是吗？我们通过在开始、中期、结束时进行结果测量来做到这一点。有些服务要求你在每次会议后都进行测量，但有些感觉像是过度了。这真的引起了我的共鸣，因为当我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时，我意识到我为每一位新病人
doing complex trauma work i was doing the same stuff you know the same stabilization program and I just thought this would be totally doable in a group um and so I put together a stabilization group and for me um I knew that a lot of the clients that I was working with would have found it really difficult being with another gender so we we made it male or female now and you know we now operate in a slightly different context and so how I would do that now I think we'd have to take some additional thoughts and consideration but if it was their cameras were on or the gallery wasn't on maybe it wouldn't really matter I don't
进行复杂创伤工作时，我都在做同样的事情，同样的稳定化程序。我只是觉得这在小组中完全是可行的。所以我组织了一个稳定化小组。对我来说，我知道我合作的许多客户会觉得与另一种性别的人在一起非常困难，所以我们现在把它分成了男性或女性。你知道，我们现在在稍微不同的背景下运作，所以如果我现在要这样做，我想我们必须进行一些额外的思考和考虑。但如果他们的摄像头是开着的，或者画廊视图没开，也许这真的没关系。我不
know something to consider I'll ask you about your experience with that in a minute as well but we then so I started this group and it worked really well um and then um the pandemic came along and so then we were doing some bits online as well um actually also in my own business I then I did a pre-record course which I was calling the feel better academy which guides people through all of this stuff because um you know whilst connection is important it still takes you know person hours doesn't it to deliver it and some people want to just be able to get the skills but not actually necessarily aren't ready for the connection as yet. So how have you navigated the kind of gender, you know, because often the complex trauma
知道，这是需要考虑的事情。我一会儿也会问你关于这方面的经验。但我们当时……所以我开始了这组，它运作得非常好。然后疫情来了，所以我们也在线做了一些部分。实际上，在我自己的业务中，我做了一个预录课程，我称之为“感觉更好学院”（Feel Better Academy），它引导人们完成所有这些事情。因为，你知道，虽然联系很重要，但交付它仍然需要人时，不是吗？有些人只是想能够获得技能，但并不一定准备好进行联系。那么你是如何处理性别问题的呢？因为通常复杂创伤
presentation is, well, it's from childhood and it might be that it's arisen because of specific genders. So then this is for our audience being vulnerable and around people of that gender can feel really triggering for people, understandably. How have you navigated that, Amy? So our groups are mixed gender, but prior to anyone kind of accessing that particular group, they will have a formulation or some kind of assessment where those kinds of things would be discussed and often you know it's kind of a mixed bag really actually in terms of whether people feel comfortable with a group program or not and sometimes there is that
的表现是源于童年，而且可能是因为特定性别而产生的。所以对于我们的听众来说，在这种性别的人周围感到脆弱可能会让人觉得非常容易触发，这是可以理解的。艾米，你是如何处理这个问题的？我们的小组是混合性别的，但在任何人进入该特定小组之前，他们会进行构思或某种评估，在评估中会讨论这些事情。通常，你知道，人们是否觉得小组项目舒服，这真的是因人而异。有时会有那种
uncertainty because often complex trauma stems from relations with other people. And with that relational trauma, there's going to be anxiety around interacting in groups. There's going to be that fear of being triggered. So we have a mixed gender group. But alongside those 12 group sessions, we provide three individual sessions that group members have prior to starting the group midway through and at the end and during those one-to-one sessions there's the opportunity to discuss any anxieties or concerns and to also problem solve and think about how best to support individuals much of that is talking about, I guess, the kind of expectations for the group in terms of what they can expect from the group. So there's, you know, there's no
不确定性，因为复杂创伤通常源于与他人的关系。有了那种关系创伤，在小组中互动就会产生焦虑。会有被触发的恐惧。所以我们有一个混合性别的小组。但在那 12 次小组会议之外，我们还提供三次个人会议，小组成员在开始小组之前、中期和结束时进行。在那些一对一的会议中，有机会讨论任何焦虑或担忧，也可以解决问题，并思考如何最好地支持个人。其中大部分是在谈论，我想，对小组的期望，即他们可以从小组中期待什么。所以，你知道，没有
expectation or pressure for anyone to talk about their traumatic experiences where they're purely for that first stabilization part. So to take those strategies and to learn more and we have a conversation about how to keep safe during the group and outside of the group sessions what will we do if someone feels triggered how will we manage that as a group and there's a real emphasis in the group particularly in the first couple of sessions about safety and connectedness so how we can ensure that all of our group members feel safe in that space and feel comfortable and also how we stay connected because we know that dissociation is a really common survival strategy and when triggered in the group likelihood is that dissociation will become activated um and then how do people cope
任何期望或压力让任何人谈论他们的创伤经历。他们纯粹是为了那第一阶段的稳定化。所以要采取这些策略并学习更多。我们进行了一次关于如何在小组期间和小组会议之外保持安全的对话。如果有人感到被触发，我们会怎么做？我们作为一个小组将如何管理它？小组中特别是在前几次会议中，非常强调安全和联系。所以我们如何确保我们所有的小组成员在那个空间里感到安全和舒适，以及我们如何保持联系。因为我们知道解离是一种非常常见的生存策略，当在小组中被触发时，解离很可能会被激活。
and reconnect safely um that being said we do also offer this particular group program as a brief psychological intervention on a one-to-one um so if at the point of formulation, there were real strong aversions to working with or being exposed to a person of another gender, we can consider actually, is it more appropriate and more useful to this person to offer them this support on a one to one basis? So that's that's kind of how we've been tackling it thus far. We do, when we're talking to people about joining this particular group therapy, talk to them about the pros of group therapy as well, because although a daunting experience, and often people do feel anxious about that, there are lots of pros. Again, thinking about that nature of complex trauma and that relational trauma. Of course, being around other people, that threat system is going to become activated.
然后人们如何应对并安全地重新连接？话虽如此，我们也确实将这个特定的小组项目作为一对一的简短心理干预提供。所以，如果在构思阶段，对与另一种性别的人工作或接触有非常强烈的反感，我们可以考虑，为这个人提供一对一的支持是否更合适、更有用？所以这就是我们迄今为止处理它的方式。当我们与人们谈论加入这个特定的团体治疗时，我们确实会与他们谈论团体治疗的优点。因为虽然这是一个令人生畏的经历，而且人们通常会对此感到焦虑，但有很多优点。再次思考复杂创伤和关系创伤的本质。当然，在其他人周围，那个威胁系统会被激活。
And we talk to people about, you know, with this being a therapy group, there's multiple therapists there to help contain that group space. Being surrounded by people with similar experiences who are also working towards similar goals can be really encouraging and really invalidating. And so also, you know, a group therapy being an opportunity to safely sort of tackle those beliefs and anxieties about other people um but again it's it's a real important um ethos in our service to consider right thing right order right time so if a group therapy is not the right thing right now for someone it may be that we offer them this program on a one-to-one instead um and support them moving forward oh it sounds like such a responsive compassionate service to work in um well that just sounds really nice sounds
我们告诉人们，你知道，这是一个治疗小组，有多个治疗师在那里帮助包容那个小组空间。被有相似经历、也朝着相似目标努力的人包围，可以非常令人鼓舞和肯定。所以，团体治疗也是一个安全地处理对他人信念和焦虑的机会。但同样，在我们服务中，考虑“正确的事情、正确的顺序、正确的时间”是一个非常重要的精神。所以如果团体治疗现在对某人来说不是正确的事情，我们可能会为他们提供一对一的项目，并支持他们前进。哦，听起来这是一个非常有响应性、富有同情心的服务。嗯，这听起来真的很好，听起来
really nice and i hope that you're getting wonderful subjective feedback as well as objective feedback because sometimes that's the stuff that really helps as a clinician isn't it when you're getting actually when this was done and when you did this it really made me feel this and this is how this has made a difference in my life it's those golden moments isn't it that just I think stay with you probably for the rest of your career that you can really reflect on most definitely um and whilst there isn't that expectation to talk about um traumatic experiences people do in the group talk about you know for example this happened to me last week and i felt really triggered and we'll relate that to what we've learned in the group um you know how that makes sense based upon what we know about the way brains work and
真的很好。我希望你不仅能得到客观的反馈，也能得到美妙的主观反馈。因为有时作为临床医生，当你得到“实际上，当这样做时，这真的让我感觉到了这一点，这就是它如何改变了我的生活”的反馈时，这真的很有帮助。这些是金子般的时刻，不是吗？我认为它们可能会伴随你整个职业生涯，你可以真正反思。绝对是。虽然没有谈论创伤经历的期望，但人们在小组中确实会谈论，例如“上周发生了这件事，我感到非常被触发”，我们会将其与我们在小组中学到的东西联系起来。你知道，基于我们对大脑运作方式的了解，这如何说得通，以及
and the way brains and memories work during traumatic experiences and I think often people find that to be really helpful that validation um of their experience and their difficulties and and linking that in with what we're learning in the group. And I think having that space to connect with others is something people have found really valuable and shared with us too. And even some of the concepts, we talk quite a lot about the window of tolerance. So that way of helping to gauge your emotions
大脑和记忆在创伤经历中是如何运作的。我认为人们通常会发现这种验证非常有帮助，对他们的经历和困难的验证，并将这与我们在小组中学到的东西联系起来。我认为拥有那个与他人联系的空间是人们发现非常有价值的东西，也与我们分享了。甚至是一些概念，我们谈论了很多关于“容忍之窗”（window of tolerance）。所以那种帮助衡量你的情绪
and your levels of arousals based upon kind of different things that happen and and how we can cope with that and I think that's been a real learning point for people and a really helpful experience so there's always opportunity within the group sessions to share that experience and to share how you're finding the group and And again, in those one-to-one sessions, we always provide that opportunity to reflect upon what is helpful in the group, what's been unhelpful or challenging, how do we problem solve that,
和你的唤醒水平的方法，基于发生的各种事情，以及我们如何应对它。我认为这对人们来说是一个真正的学习点，也是一个非常有帮助的经历。所以小组会议中总是有机会分享那种体验，并分享你对小组的感受。同样，在那些一对一的会议中，我们总是提供机会来反思小组中什么是有帮助的，什么是无益的或具有挑战性的，我们如何解决这个问题，
how do we help you? But also recognizing that with that therapist to service user relationship, for some, it might not always be easy to highlight or bring up or speak about things that have been difficult or things that haven't been the most positive experience so we also do give all of our group members um like a feedback form um like link that they can complete um and they can just say what they want to about that group experience and it's
我们如何帮助你？但也认识到，在那种治疗师与服务使用者的关系中，对有些人来说，强调、提出或谈论困难的事情或不是最积极的经历的事情可能并不总是容易的。所以我们也给所有的小组成员提供了一个反馈表链接，他们可以完成。他们可以就那种小组体验说他们想说的任何话，而且
all anonymous so we'll not know who it that group experience and it's all anonymous so we'll not know who it's come from and that's been really really helpful as well lovely and just yeah I think it's just utter magic when your group members are hearing bits from people's lives over the week and And then one of them might say, Oh, I wonder if actually this is that thing that we were talking about the other week. And could it be this and, you know, might this have been useful? And, you know, they start to kind of really apply the theory to the practice, or someone will say, actually, in the moment, I recognize that this was this and I did this.
它是完全匿名的，所以我们不会知道是谁提供的。这也非常非常有帮助。太好了。是的，我认为当你的小组成员在这一周里听到人们生活中的点滴，然后其中一个人可能会说：“哦，我想知道这是否就是我们上周谈论的那件事？可能是这个吗？你知道，这可能有用吗？”然后他们开始真正地将理论应用于实践，或者有人会说：“实际上，在那一刻，我意识到这就是这个，我做了这个。”
And it, you know, or I used to love it when people would come in and they would be, you'd see, oh, you get it. You're not using these skills. You know, they might be sharing an office with somebody and they'd be like, and I just looked at them as they were telling a story and I just realized how unregulated they were. And I just said, take a breath, drop your shoulders. And then you're like, oh, and then once you begin to be able to see how unregulated, once you begin to see what regulation looks like in you, you begin to see how unregulated other people are and once you begin to see that you can then begin to shape the world and you are a more compassionate better human and you are just more stable and you are you have a different impact on the world I think have you experienced any of that absolutely um I think even as a practitioner like delivering the group, you learn so much as you're supporting people, too.
这，你知道，或者我过去很喜欢人们进来，你会看到，哦，你明白了。你正在使用这些技能。你知道，他们可能和某人共用一个办公室，他们会说：“当他们讲故事时，我看着他们，我意识到他们是多么不受调节。我只是说，深呼吸，放下肩膀。”然后你会觉得，哦，一旦你开始能够看到不受调节是什么样子，一旦你开始看到调节在你自己身上是什么样子，你就会开始看到其他人是多么不受调节。一旦你开始看到这一点，你就可以开始塑造世界，你是一个更有同情心、更好的人，你更稳定，你对世界有不同的影响。我想，你经历过这些吗？绝对是。我认为即使作为一名从业者，在带领小组时，你在支持他人的同时，自己也学到了很多。
And it's absolutely the case. Like once you're able to better regulate, you start to notice that dysregulation in others and how you can support them. And that's even been feedback that we've had from people completing the group. One of the biggest things that some people have taken away with them is that self-awareness and that ability to recognize where they them not only in helping to regulate themselves but some of our group members have have spoken to me about how that's then helped them to recognize that dysregulation in their children or in other people around them and then support them to notice what's going on to take that step back like you say that breath drop the shoulders um so it's been a really a really positive experience yeah I love it and sometimes my kids especially my youngest will say to me mummy it's all right let's come and have a cuddle have a sit down like we'll just sit on the sofa and it's oh you're gonna be okay you're gonna be okay kid like you're attuned
确实如此。一旦你能够更好地调节，你就会开始注意到他人的失调，以及你如何能够支持他们。这甚至是我们从完成小组的人那里得到的反馈。有些人带走的最大收获之一就是那种自我意识，以及识别他们自己的能力。这不仅有助于调节他们自己，我们的一些小组成员还告诉我，这如何帮助他们识别孩子或周围其他人身上的失调，然后支持他们注意到正在发生的事情，退后一步，就像你说的，深呼吸，放下肩膀。所以这确实是一个非常积极的经历。是的，我喜欢它。有时我的孩子们，尤其是最小的那个，会对我说：“妈妈，没关系，过来抱抱，坐下来。”就像我们只是坐在沙发上，然后说：“哦，你会没事的，你会没事的，孩子。”就像你很协调，
and you're not making me feel awful for being a little bit shoutier or you know have you had a tricky day mummy like what's going on yeah she doesn't it doesn't call me mummy publicly anymore so to save his embarrassment I will I will say in public he calls me mum behind closed doors he does still call me mummy and I love it um but yeah like the window of tolerance is just so so useful and I think about it all the time and it's the it's what I call the roadmap for all of the work that I do with my clients but another of my favorites is this idea of um I don't know if you've if you've kind of got this concept in your group, but a bicycle wheel. And like we might just kind of notice things arise on the rim and we can choose where to show, you know, to pay our attention. And then there's part of that. There's a really nice kind of guided imagery exercise where you imagine yourself sitting at the bottom of an
你没有因为我有点大声而让我感觉很糟糕，或者“妈妈，你今天过得很难吗？发生了什么事？”是的，他不再在公共场合叫我妈妈了，为了避免尴尬，我会说在公共场合他叫我“妈”，在私下里他仍然叫我“妈妈”，我喜欢它。但是，是的，容忍之窗真的非常非常有用，我一直都在想它。这就是我称之为我与客户所做所有工作的路线图。但我最喜欢的另一个概念是，我不知道你是否在你的小组中有这个概念，一个自行车轮。我们可能会注意到事情出现在轮辋上，我们可以选择在哪里展示，你知道，去关注。然后这是其中的一部分。有一个非常好的引导意象练习，你想象自己坐在
ocean you can breathe you know you're not you're not struggling for breath or anything it's supposed to be tranquil and you just are looking up towards the surface and you might be able to see the sort of choppy waves you might be able to see the sun coming down but you're not you're not in the thick of that and so it's that ability to kind of just slightly absent yourself to be able to think about what is whipping you up into a frenzy and whether that actually is deserving of your time and attention right now and just slowing everything down I really love that have you got a favorite kind of strategy or thing from your group that actually you just love doing or that you use for yourself that is a very good question um I think it really depends to be honest what you need in the moment
海洋底部，你可以呼吸，你知道你没有在为呼吸而挣扎，它应该是宁静的，你只是向上看着水面，你可能会看到那种波涛汹涌的海浪，你可能会看到阳光照下来，但你并没有身处其中。所以这是一种能够稍微让自己抽离的能力，能够思考是什么让你陷入了狂热，以及这是否真的值得你现在的时间和注意力，并让一切慢下来。我真的很喜欢那个。你有没有从你的小组中得到一种你最喜欢的策略或东西，你真的很喜欢做，或者你自己使用的？这是一个非常好的问题。嗯，我认为这真的取决于，老实说，你在那一刻需要什么。
and that's something that we talk to people in the group about all of the time you know there's lots of different ways that we can help ourselves to regulate um and you'll need different things at different times based upon where you are on that bicycle wheel or where you are um you know in that window of tolerance I think for me one of my personal favorites is just using your senses to soothe you and reground you um because i think when we think about complex trauma and just generally day-to-day like life stresses that we experience that information comes in through our senses essentially and and travels up to the you know through the nervous system up to the brain and sends that particular message and i just find it really interesting how we can use that same process to reground and re-regulate ourselves and I think if you know when we think back to being a child
这也是我们在小组中一直与人们谈论的事情。你知道，有很多不同的方法可以帮助我们调节。根据你在那个自行车轮上的位置，或者你在那个容忍之窗中的位置，你在不同时间需要不同的东西。我认为对我来说，我个人最喜欢的方法之一就是利用你的感官来安抚和重新定位自己。因为我认为当我们想到复杂创伤以及我们经历的日常压力时，这些信息本质上是通过我们的感官进入的，并沿着神经系统传到大脑，发送那个特定的信息。我发现我们如何利用同样的过程来重新定位和重新调节自己，这非常有趣。我认为如果你，当我们回想童年
or when we think about children around us a lot of the time the things that they need or want for self-regulation relates to senses like children come to adults or parents around us for a hug you know that's a tactile um touch response or sense um and I find that that really interesting because I think especially when you're an adult it can sometimes be more difficult to know what do I do like when I was a kid I would want a hug but I can't always get a hug um and I think the senses are just a lovely way of bringing that in um and I often think sharing that kind of sensory understanding and that neurobiological understanding behind the skill is something that people really find um almost like a light bulb moment I think a lot of
或者当我们想到周围的孩子时，很多时候他们需要或想要自我调节的东西与感官有关。比如孩子们来到成年人或父母身边寻求拥抱，你知道，那是一种触觉反应或感官。我发现这非常有趣，因为我认为特别是当你是一个成年人时，有时更难知道我该做什么。就像我小时候，我会想要一个拥抱，但我不能总是得到一个拥抱。我认为感官是一种很好的引入方式。而且我经常认为分享那种感官理解和技能背后的神经生物学理解是人们真正发现的，几乎像是一个“顿悟时刻”。我想很多人
people when when you kind of suggest it to them at first they're like well how is listening to the sounds of rain and and lighting a candle going to soothe me but when you explain that and the importance of engaging all of those senses at once it seems to click so much and it's just one that I personally find to be the most soothing for me as well thank you for running with that question that I threw at you you did a beautiful job of it I've got a candle burning right now I just yeah for me it feels like a little bit of me indulgence time and I just yeah love everything you said basically I'm such a mammal um I am five foot six and my husband is six foot two I'm gonna say and I just still love a cuddle stand-up cuddles
当你第一次向他们建议时，他们会说：“听雨声和点蜡烛怎么能安抚我？”但当你解释这一点，以及同时调动所有这些感官的重要性时，它似乎就非常契合了。这只是我个人觉得对我来说最安抚的一种。谢谢你回答了我抛给你的那个问题，你做得非常漂亮。我现在正点着一支蜡烛，我只是，是的，对我来说，这感觉像是一点点自我放纵的时间，我只是，是的，基本上喜欢你所说的一切。我是一个哺乳动物。我身高 5 英尺 6 英寸，我丈夫身高 6 英尺 2 英寸，我想说，我仍然喜欢拥抱，站着拥抱
the best does that sound really dodgy um you know just I like I like cuddles and sometimes I'll say I think I need a hug um and if my little one's upset he still likes to scooch up like and have like a koala hug um I can sort of just about manage to hold him like that and just you know I just love it and like as a mummy I'm the sort of person that will scooch down to the floor and like shuffle him onto my knee and then just sort of sit there as we have a chat and we'll I still do that with my big one as well at bedtime I get him to sit on my knee or sit on stairs with me to hear about their day I'm just a mammal and at night time I don't mind sharing
是最好的。这听起来很奇怪吗？你知道，我只是喜欢拥抱。有时我会说：“我想我需要一个拥抱。”如果我的小家伙心烦意乱，他仍然喜欢蹭过来，像考拉一样拥抱。我勉强能那样抱着他，你知道，我只是喜欢它。作为妈妈，我是那种会蹲到地板上，让他挪到我膝盖上，然后我们就坐在那里聊天的人。我仍然会在睡前和我的大孩子那样做，我让他坐在我膝盖上，或者和我坐在楼梯上听他们讲他们的一天。我只是一个哺乳动物。在晚上，我不介意与
with you all that at night time as we're watching tv my husband fusses my hair for me like I love a bit of stroking I love a bit of just a little bit of yeah I'm just a mammal you know I'd be the sort of monkey that would sit sit being groomed or grooming others in a row and even at primary school we used to do that we used to sit in a row doing each other's hair and stroking each other's backs and stuff like not everyone is into sensory stuff but actually what we know about living in groups is that you know it's supposed to feel good but for some reasons stuff that's happened in our past it can feel triggering can't it absolutely um and that again is why it's so important in the group for us to give people a range of different skills that they
你们所有人分享，在晚上我们看电视时，我丈夫会为我梳理头发。我喜欢一点抚摸，我喜欢一点点，是的，我只是一个哺乳动物，你知道。我会是那种坐在那里被梳理毛发或梳理他人的猴子。即使在小学时，我们也这样做，我们过去常坐成一排，互相梳理头发，抚摸对方的背部之类的。不是每个人都喜欢感官方面的东西，但实际上，我们所知道的关于群体生活的是，你知道，它应该感觉很好。但由于过去发生的一些事情，它可能会让人觉得被触发，不是吗？绝对是。嗯，这再次说明了为什么在小组中为人们提供一系列不同的技能对我们来说非常重要，
use because some people will not be drawn to like self-soothing with the senses um and not only that but i guess also highlighting the importance in the group of using the skills in a way that works for you and a way that feels manageable for you um and sometimes you know it might be that there are certain parts of self-soothing with the senses for for example, that people really enjoy, but it might be the touch aspect that they don't enjoy. And knowing it's okay to not engage that sense and just roll with the ones that work for you. Similarly, some of the other skills, again, people will find them really interesting
因为有些人不会被那种利用感官的自我安抚所吸引。不仅如此，我想这也强调了在小组中以适合你的方式和让你觉得可控的方式使用这些技能的重要性。有时，你知道，可能在利用感官进行自我安抚的某些部分，例如，人们非常喜欢，但可能触觉方面是他们不喜欢的。知道不参与那种感官是可以的，只使用那些对你有用的感官。同样，其他一些技能，人们也会觉得它们非常有趣
and be really drawn to them. And for others, it will feel really triggering one of the the other skills that we go over is imagining that calm place um and for some that's really really soothing but for others that the idea of that in itself can be triggering because there is no place that they felt calm or safe before um and yeah i think that's just really important to to acknowledge and and something that we kind of preface with the the group sessions as well because there are a lot of different skills that we go over we go through distress tolerance and emotion regulation skills from dbt we go through um skills from like cft as well so things like the soothing rhythm breathing um developing that
并被它们所吸引。而对其他人来说，这会让人觉得非常容易触发。我们回顾的另一种技能是想象那个平静的地方。对有些人来说，这非常非常安抚，但对其他人来说，这个想法本身就可能触发，因为他们以前没有感到平静或安全的地方。是的，我认为承认这一点非常重要，这也是我们在小组会议中预先说明的事情。因为我们回顾了很多不同的技能，我们经历了 DBT（辩证行为疗法）中的痛苦耐受和情绪调节技能，我们也经历了来自 CFT（同情聚焦疗法）的技能，比如舒缓的节奏呼吸，发展那种
compassionate self um and each of those will land differently with different people and that's okay it's about developing the toolkit that works for you and you know what might work really well for us where we just talked about you know that sensory aspect for some that will just feel completely overwhelming and overstimulating and not the thing that they need so yeah just about individualizing things absolutely when i used to run the group in person i used to take um a white company cassis spray with me and i'd sort of spray the room so that we're kind of starting to establish like a safe, comforting, calming scent. Unfortunately, they don't make that scent anymore.
同情心，每一种方法对不同的人产生的影响都不同，这没关系。关键在于建立一套适合你自己的工具箱。你知道，我们刚才谈到的感官方面，对某些人来说可能完全是压倒性的、过度刺激的，并不是他们所需要的。所以，关键在于个性化。绝对是这样。我以前亲自主持小组时，会带上一瓶The White Company的Cassis喷雾，我会喷洒房间，这样我们就能开始建立一种安全、舒适、平静的氛围。遗憾的是，他们不再生产那种香味了。
But it was still something I used to say with online work. You can kind of spray the room like something that can be something new so that you begin to associate that with something calm, stable, secure and OK. Thank you. That's been really interesting to hear more about your programme. In terms of how you get it published, you know, does this class's audit where you don't need ethics? Do you kind of need to go through the ethical hoops? How has that worked out for you? So a colleague of mine led on this particular piece of research um actually as part of her training for the doctorate in clinical psychology um so it was something that i supported her with so she i will give all credit to her in terms of doing all of the wonderful things like setting up the research and all of our questions and organising ethical approval and whether that was needed and that kind of thing.
但这仍然是我在网上工作时会提到的方法。你可以喷洒房间，让它成为一种新的东西，这样你就可以开始把它与平静、稳定、安全和良好的感觉联系起来。谢谢。听到更多关于你的项目的信息非常有趣。关于你是如何发表它的，你知道，这种课程审计是否不需要伦理审查？你需要经历伦理审查的繁琐程序吗？这对你来说是如何运作的？我的一位同事领导了这项特定的研究，实际上是作为她临床心理学博士培训的一部分，所以我支持了她。因此，我会把所有的功劳都归功于她，因为她做了所有了不起的事情，比如建立研究、提出所有问题、组织伦理审批以及是否需要这些审批等等。
And my role was predominantly from delivering the group and collecting all of the the information um but this particular piece of um research as such is it kind of more comes under the remit of like audit and evaluation um so we didn't need kind of full ethical approval just talking more so to like um just to like the the internal committees within um research and development and um that kind of department in in the trust fabulous and you really nicely demonstrated how you can get involved in research so um when i was an assistant i definitely helped support trainees um and they agreed that I could kind of put that as kind of honorary research work on my on my forms and I helped with some research when I was an assistant which then got me my first publication which then allowed me to do
我的角色主要是负责开展小组活动和收集所有信息。但这项特定的研究更属于审计和评估的范畴，所以我们不需要全面的伦理审批，只是更多地与研究与发展部门以及信托机构内部的委员会进行沟通。太棒了，你很好地展示了如何参与研究。当我还是助理时，我确实帮助支持过实习生，他们同意我可以把这作为荣誉研究工作写在我的表格上。当我还是助理时，我参与了一些研究，这让我获得了第一次发表论文的机会，然后让我能够进行
a presentation which counted as a dissemination so I really do think that if you're looking to progress your career in psychology that getting involved in research is so so important do you want to name check your colleague whose research this is I absolutely will my colleague is Alana Foreman and she is doing some wonderful things like this piece of research lovely is it open access can anybody kind of read the whole thing or is it just the abstract they can read? I believe it's open access. I don't currently, our trust doesn't have like access
一次演讲，这算作一次传播。所以我真的认为，如果你想在心理学领域发展你的职业生涯，参与研究是非常非常重要的。你想提一下你的同事的名字吗？这项研究是谁的？我当然会。我的同事是Alana Foreman，她正在做一些很棒的事情，比如这项研究。太好了，它是开放获取的吗？任何人都可以阅读全文，还是只能阅读摘要？我相信它是开放获取的。我目前，我们的信托机构没有权限访问
to all publications, but I can download it and read it. So it should be available. But for those who are registered, like studying university or something, they'll be able to access it anyway. Okay, I will make sure that I pop a link to it in the show notes. So if anybody wants to be able to take a read of it, they absolutely can. Before we finish, have you got any advice for any aspiring psychologists out there to reduce burnout, Amy? in this career pathway and trying to reach certain goalposts within certain times and get experience for this for your application and go experience here and there but I think one of
所有出版物，但我可以下载并阅读它。所以它应该是可用的。但对于那些注册的人，比如在大学学习的人，他们无论如何都能访问它。好的，我会确保在节目笔记中放一个链接。所以如果有人想阅读它，他们绝对可以。在我们结束之前，Amy，你对任何有抱负的心理学家有什么减少职业倦怠的建议吗？在这个职业道路上，试图在特定时间内达到某些目标，为申请积累经验，到处获取经验，但我认为其中之一
or there's a couple of things I'd suggest really is making sure that what you're doing is not only for the purpose of gaining experience, but also something that you genuinely really enjoy and feel interested in, because that will make such a difference to you day to day. And as I say, recognising those limits, I think we in this career path have a lot of perfectionism, and that can drive us to push a lot of the time and and in some ways that's a really brilliant trait but also what is very helpful is being able to recognize when you need to take a step back and when you need to look after yourself um and i think just one of the the biggest pieces of advice i would give particularly for those either getting onto the doctorate now pushing to get there already studying is just to look after yourself outside of work and outside of studying do the
或者我有几点建议，确实是确保你所做的事情不仅是为了获得经验，而且是你真正喜欢并感兴趣的事情，因为这会对你的日常工作产生很大的影响。正如我所说，认识到这些限制，我认为我们在职业道路上有很强的完美主义倾向，这在很多时候会驱使我们不断前进，在某些方面这是一种非常出色的特质，但非常有帮助的是能够认识到什么时候需要退后一步，什么时候需要照顾好自己。我认为我能给出的最大建议之一，特别是对于那些现在正在攻读博士学位或已经在学习的人，就是要在工作和学习之外照顾好自己，做
things that feel nourishing to you say no when you need to prioritize you and your time and rest time and know that rest is just as productive as doing. Beautiful, so lovely and so important. Amy, thank you so much for speaking with us. It's been incredible. It's not a topic that we've covered trauma stabilisation, but it's so important. And actually, what we found is that sometimes people choose not to go on to process their traumas, because they are feeling that they can manage everything so much better. So things do stay in their box more and we can think about it as phases of internet intervention so maybe we do the stabilization phase and maybe in a couple of years they might feel ready and have the necessary bolt-on skills to be able to tolerate that
那些让你感到滋养的事情，在需要优先考虑自己、时间和休息时说不，并知道休息和行动一样富有成效。太美了，太可爱了，也太重要了。Amy，非常感谢你与我们交谈。这太不可思议了。创伤稳定化是我们没有涉及的话题，但它非常重要。实际上，我们发现有时人们选择不去处理他们的创伤，因为他们觉得他们能更好地管理一切。所以事情更多地留在盒子里，我们可以把它看作是干预的阶段，所以也许我们先进行稳定阶段，也许几年后他们可能会感到准备好了，并具备了必要的附加技能来更好地忍受
processing stage better absolutely and that's why it's so important to think about right order right thing right time absolutely thank you so much for your time it's been a beautiful episode thanks amy thank you for having me marion you're so welcome thank you so much to our guest amy i think she's just doing an incredible job and the service sound like a really brilliant service to be part of, very thoughtful, compassionate, empathic, and hopefully the clients are finding it to be a really, really valuable service. What has this evoked for you? Has this made you think about whether you could deliver something similar in future? Has it made you think about whether you'd like to learn some trauma stabilization skills to either help yourself or to help the clients you're working with? Do check out the
处理阶段。绝对是这样，这就是为什么考虑正确的顺序、正确的事情、正确的时间如此重要。绝对的，非常感谢你的时间，这是一个美丽的节目。谢谢Amy。谢谢你邀请我，Marion。不客气。非常感谢我们的嘉宾Amy，我认为她做得非常出色，这个服务听起来是一个非常棒的服务，非常体贴、富有同情心、善解人意，希望客户们能发现这是一个非常有价值的服务。这引起了你什么共鸣？这是否让你思考未来是否可以提供类似的服务？这是否让你思考是否想学习一些创伤稳定技能来帮助自己或帮助你正在合作的客户？请查看
Feel Better Academy, which is available on the short course area of my website, which is www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash short hyphen courses where you can get the Feel Better Academy for £49.99 which will help you as an aspiring psychologist or clinician to be able to learn those skills, those strategies to be able to help yourself and the clients you work with. I would love any feedback you've got about this episode. Please do come along and follow me on socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere, but also come and join the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist community, and let me know what you think there too. Take a moment to rate and review the podcast. It would be so appreciated. It's the kindest free thing you can do for me. And please also, if you're watching
Feel Better Academy，它可以在我网站的短期课程区域找到，网址是www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/short-courses，在那里你可以以49.99英镑的价格获得Feel Better Academy，这将帮助你作为一名有抱负的心理学家或临床医生学习这些技能和策略，以帮助自己和你合作的客户。我很乐意收到你对这一集的任何反馈。请一定要在社交媒体上关注我。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent，但也请加入免费的Facebook群组，Aspiring Psychologist community，并在那里让我知道你的想法。花点时间给播客评分和评论。我将不胜感激。这是你能为我做的最友善的免费事情。也请，如果你正在观看
on YouTube, please do subscribe to the channel. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Please do stay kind to yourselves. And I will be back along with the next episode, 10am on YouTube on Saturdays and 6am on Mondays for the MP3. Take care. See you very soon. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical
在YouTube上，请订阅该频道。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。请一定要善待自己。我将在下一集回来，周六上午10点在YouTube上，周一上午6点在MP3上。保重。很快见到你。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南吧。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Aspiring Psychologist Podcast。我是Dr. Marianne Trent。我的名字是Jana，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了Clinical
Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Psychologist Collective这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。